this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] we're
back [__]
it's monday the 29th of august and the
joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen
football season is about to begin for
uncle joey it began [__] saturday i
had the over on the hawaii whatever
[__] game i had to wait till two in
the morning to get results but it came
through but you get ready for nfl week
one action with draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
nfl and to celebrate the return of
football listen i know you guys were at
different [__] places last year and
you liked them or you didn't like them
but it's a whole new [__] football
season and draftkings is better than
ever i [__] love draftkings
experience the thrill of draftkings
early win promotion get up to seven and
you win bet on any nfl team of your
choice and if your team leads by seven
points at any point during the game you
get paid instantly even if your team
loses
you win who's better than draftkings
nobody they're safe secure and reliable
deposit and withdraw cash whatever the
hell you want this is your year with
draftkings plus they got a social media
page that'll rock your world you could
get together with other gamblers see
what they're betting overs learn things
so do me a favor download the draftking
sportsbook app today and use promo code
joey to get 200 and free bets instantly
when you place a five alabet on any
football team that's code joey j-o-e-y
only at draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
nfl minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details now do me a favor download the
draftking sportsbook app and get ready
to win some [__] cash
[__]
the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen unless you're santa
claus you're not looking forward to
dealing with the holiday mails and if
you haven't started prepping for the
chaos of holiday mailing shipping you've
already fallen behind guys don't get
confused it's september whatever the
[__] august
but it's starting already stamps.com is
everything you need to make life easier
it's the virtual 24 7 post office no
lines no traffic no hassle my wife and i
use stamps.com for the last 11 12 years
and we [__] love them stamp.com gives
you the access to the post office and
ups shipping services right from your
[__] computer save up to 30 off usps
rates and over 86
off ups you know uncle joey comes at you
on a monday all you need is a regular
computer and a [__] printer no
special supplies or equipment you'll be
up and running in minutes
print official postage for any letter
package anywhere anytime get ahead of
the holiday chaos this year get started
with stamps.com today i don't care if
you got a small business or 800 [__]
employees sign up with promo code joey
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com and
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and then to code joey it's that
easy and now let's get ready for this
[__] show jack
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
we're back you bad [__] it's
monday the 29th i'm sorry we had to take
the week off last week i was at the
[__] outer banks with the family and
uh
five other families 20 something people
in a [__] house it was tremendous
believing that i haven't done anything
like this
i don't think i ever did anything like
that i mean i had like my family growing
up with other people but anyway the
outer banks was beautiful
shout out to ducks donuts a bunch of
[__] places down there i mean jesus
christ they were tremendous i only had
two [__] donuts you know me i'm
paranoid of [__] diabetes and [__] i
had one donut one day
early in the morning after my workout
and one morning and one donut the other
morning and it was i did not have the
maple glaze with bacon i got to work
myself up to that [__] you know what i'm
saying everybody kept saying when i put
the picture up on instagram it was
really weird the lady at the place said
you got to try the bacon with the maple
nut whatever the [__] syrup maple syrup
and it sounded good but [__] bacon
and [__] uh whatever that that's yeah
sweet
that'll send me into another [__]
dimension so i was like
i'm not ready for it yet but it was
beautiful the [__] donuts are great
i did a lot of crazy [__] down there i
was on antibiotics for starters so the
first couple days
i swelled up from the [__] salt and
the water and not having my chair with
my feet go up and [__] but then every i
didn't lift the [__] weight i didn't
touch a [__] weight all week i just
swam every morning i would get up
i would [__] i had a nice little system
down there guys i was telling mike how
much
i missed the outdoor guys colorado was
made for a chubby [__] speck like me
i i don't know if i could describe it
any better
that state had everything that soothed
my nerves i mean not from my stories
what i was doing up there
but even bolder guys i i forgot to
mention to you guys before i left
boulder last year before i left boulder
i had weights at the house like a bench
and the bench was my dinner table
my weightlifting bench it was a [__]
where i wrote jokes that bench
i wish i could still have that bench
today it was a one and all-purpose type
of [__] thing i used to lift a lot in
colorado and swim and all that [__] but
the one thing i loved when i lived in
north boulder
was just smoking a [__] bong or two
and then rolling a [__] joint
and walking up a hill
just walk up a [__] hill
guys yeah you're a little scared you got
the mountain lions one time i didn't see
a bear but i heard that [__]
it sounds like a little bit of an
earthquake on the floor and [__]
you see trees moving weird i got the
[__] out of there
but that was part of who i was so when i
went down to you know i moved to [__]
seattle it rains kept walking that [__]
all day and then los angeles is a
[__] concrete jungle you know
and they got places to walk in los
angeles parks and [__] but i don't know
i was so into
my career i forgot all about that and
then i got to jersey two years ago and
he when i first got here for me just to
get out of my head i would go to like a
[__] softball field there's a little
league field about a mile from here and
then there's another field like football
but i would go behind like when my
daughter practices softball if you walk
behind they got a path
and there's times i've just while
they're back there i want to get away
from the mosquitoes
i take my little nature walk dog and it
does wonders for you
it really does like even now when i wake
up in the morning i do not
i'll tell you the biggest mistake i was
making i don't know how it is for you
guys
but the biggest [__] mistake
you can make today i'm gonna tell you
what it is besides drinking a coke for
breakfast or smoking a [__] cigarette
if you start the day if you get out of
bed
and you walk right to the [__]
computer
you lost
you lost and guys
i did it for [__] years where i would
you know
you get up and you go right to the
computer room with your [__] phone
and your [__] uh cup of coffee and
i'm waking up and before i could even
process what happened yesterday or
process what i'm doing today you're
getting bombarded but you know
uh
trump called her a fat [__] you know
back then when i would wake up in the
morning every day with something about
trump he called this chick a [__] pig
whatever the [__] and it wasn't just
trump i'm not i'm not talking about
trump i'm just talking about all the
[__] all the and i hate saying that
word the negativity but all this [__]
that's got nothing to do with you
at six o'clock in the morning
i don't know what it was i thought that
i think that that was a trigger for my
just getting into the shower and going
what the [__]
you know this is happening this is
happening kobe you know so now when i
wake up in the [__] morning for
the last two and a half years
i i don't even go to that [__] that
area i get my cup of coffee
and i go and i sit in a chair we all
have a [__] chair
if you don't have a chair get a [__]
milk crate it worked for me for years
okay go to 7-eleven at night they got
the milk crates out there steal them i
got 10 of these [__] crates that's
how i do them one a week you steal some
[__] milk crates i don't care if you
got to put one on top of that they got
those long ones like the ones i have the
alma and then the regular milk ones i
don't like these but they got those
[__] big ones i used to sit on one of
those
just sit outside
i don't give a [__] if it's 10
even last winter i went outside every
morning
every [__] morning in the snow
you build a little trench for yourself
like a little igloo [__] spot
and drink that coffee or drink your
protein drink i don't know what the [__]
you drink in the morning you're [__]
soy latte
and just look at the clouds look at the
sky and process what happened last night
process what happened yesterday and
process what needs to be done today
i i got to tell you something it's a
[__] game changer if you wake up in
the morning you go right on instagram
and twitter and this chick showing a
[__] you got this chick sucking a [__]
you got [__] this guy talking about
who's who's
who hates joe rogan what the [__] aaron
whatever said on there but you know
you're gonna die
your mind cannot handle and that's
what's going on right now there is so
much [__] information thrown at you
that you can't [__] process it you
know and i learned this guys i was dying
in [__] anxiety for five [__]
years medication breathing
i didn't know what it was and i gotta be
honest here now thinking about it yes it
was the move and the whole thing
but it was one i was sick and tired of
just doing comedy i was [__] sick and
tired of it like just i was to the point
where i just couldn't take it no more
guys the plane rides the [__] the
[__] agents it got old but besides
that it was all the information that was
getting thrown at me and i think right
now
all these people that have mental health
problems including myself
that things aren't still the same a
little right for you since the pandemic
started whatever the [__] is going on
it's because of all the [__]
information we got thrown at us
if you look at people they're going [__]
crazy
people are called [__] nuts guys i
don't know where the [__] you live in
your peaceful abode
but people are [__] going off every
[__] i went to the gym this morning i'm
on the bike they have the news on right
that the the local jersey [__] news
there was two people shot in tom's river
which is 25 minutes from me
you know
they're stealing cars in newark left and
right i mean it's just so and you start
thinking about [__] that you don't need
to be there in the morning think about
like
if you have a [__] nice car
and you live in this area or whatever
freehold what they're doing is these car
thieves get the [__] cars
at night when you're sleeping they go
through your key for even if you have
your key fob in the [__] house now
they could steal your [__] car look
at jimmy's neighbor
they got ways to steal your cars now
that
you know we did all this [__]
technology with the key problem they're
telling you to take it out of the
[__] car don't leave it how about
this one
you can't leave a default by your door
whatever the [__] they're called
because people can zone something
somebody listen i'm not a [__] genius
i'm just telling you what people say to
me and i process and go okay i won't
leave my key fob by the [__] door
okay i got it
but it's
people going off and i think part of it
is everything that gets thrown at you
all day
you know if you go right to [__]
yahoo or cnn news or whatever the [__]
it is you know i don't know who's right
i don't know who's left i don't really
give a [__]
but
you got this uh
what the [__] you got this uh
[__] go you know it's constant guys so
what i'm trying to say is you don't need
that early in the morning
and it's helped me a hundred and fifty
[__] ways to like look at that [__]
you know what my problem was my problem
was that i was always in a rush in my
mind
i gotta go i gotta i gotta finish this
and go to where the [__] are you going
where [__] are you going
guys i would wake up at four in the
morning to pee honest to god i'm being
honest with you because i you know i
would get up at four in the morning to
pee and
run over to twitter and check your [__]
like something was going to happen
nothing's going to happen
what's going to happen joe's going to
put a picture up of his [__]
bicycle i i lift it today you know
whatever [__] walk 30 minutes
whatever on the treadmill yesterday put
it up i'm in the car sitting there for
eight hours driving back from north
carolina and he puts a thing up
a fancy [__] treadmill like
everybody's got a [__] treadmill
so
it's just you know i i give it the time
that's needed
i go out there
first thing when i got my cup of coffee
i don't like people talking around me
i don't want to hear about like in this
house this last week there were maybe
two mornings that people came up biden
that i go right outside
[Music]
right now
i go right outside
you know i'm not into that i don't want
to hear that [__] at all he forgave
student loans he didn't forgive mine i
already paid it who's the [__] here
so
you know you go outside guys you say
thank you
god forgive me another [__] day how
can i be a little better than i was
yesterday
and then i give my gratitude for the day
of my five things i'm grateful for and
you know what i say i'm out loud if
you're driving by and you think i'm
crazy i don't give a [__]
okay i'm grateful for my life i'm
grateful for [__] my family whatever
the [__] you're grateful for i'm
grateful for what i have and most
importantly what i don't [__] have
how's that one for you [__]
you know for everybody who thinks you
need a lamborghini in your life you
don't need dick okay all right i would
love to live in a million dollar home a
10 million dollar home yeah it's a
million dollars a year in upkeep are you
gonna [__] do that you're gonna win
the lottery every year [__] no
you're not so
keep making those donuts
whatever it takes
i mean i'm not gonna sit out there for
two hours like a bumpy i got [__] to do
in the morning
but however long the process takes
sometimes i sit out there for 20 minutes
and my wife comes
and we discuss 10 minutes of the week of
the day what's going on then she goes
her way and i come down and start my day
with the computer emails whatever
and then from there you go to a [__]
gym whatever your [__] day is but
what i'm saying is i just don't [__]
jump on the [__] computer for
breakfast no more it's no bueno anyway i
tell you [__] what happened
last week
because you know how it is guys you sit
here
for eight [__] months nobody calls
you right nobody [__] calls you
not one person hey joe i got a job for
you but i have an agent in new york i
got two agents you know me i'm always
running with a guy on the side
i got a guy
but this guy's who bots eight months not
one [__] audition
i love him great guy but you know so now
what
anyway
so i got my little gay brother brother
i've had him he got me spider-man too
so think about how long i've known day
four dave is my brother and i have dave
moved to new york
he's my little gay brother and he just
books theater which i don't give a [__]
but i told him dave can you help me out
he goes if i see something i'll submit
you for it
so
guys i swear to god i get in the car
maybe friday afternoon we got the [__]
out of here we got a hotel halfway we
didn't want to do the whole night
sleeping we don't know if we get caught
sick i might get classic my daughter
might get caught sticks so me and one of
the other family said [__] it let's pull
over with that four and a half hour mark
that'll give us plenty of time we'll get
some dinner
got some [__] tremendous mexican food
i don't know what's going on in north
carolina
but there's more [__] mexican
restaurants in north carolina what they
are in california jack i don't know if
they tell these mexicans to move to
north carolina it's the smartest [__]
move in the world
so they don't gonna have to have han
hand to hand combat with other [__]
families
but i'll tell you something
i stopped to the mexican place
and from the outside i gave it a two
i give it go to a place and i don't even
know i'm going in there
i already see [__] and blood coming out
of my [__] [__]
you know
me my wife the other family went in
there
first off they had to put tables
together for us they had like three
different tables the last table was a
circular one
this one was like a poke card table and
this one was a nice dinner table they
had maybe
six tables in the place el cuyanco i
don't [__] know
i think it was in virginia
we go in there
the families in there they got
bulletproof glass i don't know why like
you could order food to go
they had like glass there and then they
had a little dining room area maybe five
table
i sat down
i'm like i'm gonna be a little careful
in here i'm not even gonna touch the
tables like i said they had to put three
tables together i think it was
three
it was like seven others
they had to put three tables together
all tables were all [__] different
right
so i'm not feeling confident about this
[__] place they never even had time
to go get tables and i'm saying when
they open the restaurant so
she comes over they bring chips and
salsa
chips and money sauce is [__] even
better
okay
then it comes time to order
and i ordered i wanted to be safe
so i ordered uh chicken enchiladas with
the green sauce
let me tell you something guys
i wish i would order 10 orders of it it
was so [__] good that's number one
number two i tell you what stood out
the [__] chicken
was tremendous
it was one of those roasted chickens
from costco yeah these are mexicans they
doped that [__] up jack they
doped that [__] chicken up
and they put an enchiladas in with
[__] green sauce oh my god with rice
and beans
these [__] and the bill was like
80 bucks for 15 of us so
put that in your pipe and smoke in north
carolina that was the only meal i had
out that was the only time i had out
it was [__] delicious the people were
great
that fried ice cream for the kids free
dessert the kids were [__] happy i
don't i don't
i don't like fried ice cream i don't
know i like my ice cream [__] cold
all right
i like the ice cream cold i don't want
no [__] friends
i took my daughter some place two weeks
ago
she gets the oreo pancakes i'm okay with
that it's bad enough
it came [__] eight in the morning two
[__] fried oreos up on top i'm on top
of the [__] i'm like mercy what is
that [__] i think that too forgive me
those [__] things but i like them
give me those [__] things you can't
eat a fried oreo for [__] breakfast
mercy
you [__] run home next to the car i
can't have that at eight in the morning
so
i leave here [__] friday right get
there saturday
having a great time monday morning 901 i
got a [__] email
can you make up your mind on this offer
i got an offer to myself so i'm sitting
like i told you [__]
you never know what's gonna [__]
happen when you go away
nobody bothers you i would sit at home
for two weeks
and the minute the uber would come and i
would close the door on the uber i swear
to god guys i would just close the door
on the uber the guy would go airport
yeah yeah yeah
not even five seconds
right away my agent what's up hey you
have an audition tomorrow for a [__]
movie
you miserable [__]
all week i've been sitting here with my
finger up my ass going to [__]
hanging out with lee and edibles nobody
[__] calls
and now you want to [__] call me
today as i'm leaving so sure enough
monday i get this long email about this
pilot they want to use me blah blah blah
they want a picture of me with the kid
you know just
really
i want to think about this [__] right
now
i didn't even reply
i was like [__] it i'll deal with this
later
the next day you ready for this
[__]
i get an email from my little man dave
guys you ready for this one
he got me an audition for a play
for guys and dolls
for the role of big [__] jewels
but no no it gets better
it's a three-week run at the kennedy
center in washington [__] dc
and the nation's capital
and i'm sitting there going let me call
this [__]
i call him up he's in england hi i'm
like what's going on because i came to
england for a party i'm like listen what
is this
what is this and he's like joey this is
big time
he goes you [__] do it to me all the
time
he goes they call me they ask me for my
client list i send it and they want to
talk to you i don't know why i don't
know what you're doing over there i go
but dave a [__] play
i could see if it's like a a play off
broadway that's who i am i'm i'm not
good enough i've never done it i've
given i did a play one time i got fired
in l.a the worst play in the world huh
so i look at this [__] audition
i haven't seen guys in dolls the movie
in 30 [__] years you know
[Music]
yeah everybody does the play in high
school i didn't do [__] plays in high
school so i missed that on [__] guys
and dolls i called nick datura
i asked him for advice he's like [__]
do it
it's [__] tremendous send it in he
goes who are you reading for big jewels
i'm gonna hide you know he goes you're
perfect for [__] jewels and george
some other [__] guy and i'm like are
you guys serious
so i'm like holy [__] so i called
another dear friend of mine and i'm like
hey i gotta run this by you
she almost fainted
she almost fainted she's a play check
you know she almost fainted on the phone
she's like ah are you [__] serious
you're definitely doing that oh my god
she goes i love that place she goes who
are you reading for big jewels like oh
yeah
and she's like you gotta [__] do it
so tomorrow
i'm putting this [__] audition on
tape
i wanted to come home i'm gonna put a
suit on
i'm gonna [__] look smoke and i'm
gonna because the road is for a 60 year
old guy it's an old guy so
i'm not i don't have to dye my hair i'm
gonna do dick it said right on the thing
no singing no dancing
because a lot of you is at home going
joey you got a dead listen my mumbo days
are [__] over okay i could wiggle a
little bit
but my mambo days are [__] over so
i'm going for it
why not what's the worst [__] say to me
no who cares i move on we come back we
do the podcast and we still got and it's
only like a three week run it's like
october
like a couple weekends yeah that's it no
no no no the whole week it's seven days
a week
every day you gotta stay down there
every [__] night
where the [__] matinee on saturdays
and sundays
i think it's like two weekends and
two and a half weeks or whatever guys
listen
i mean i'm getting old this would be a
great experience for me you know i could
and it's something i want to do and i
can drive to dc you know i'm saying i
have to fly waste my [__] time
because i don't want to go into dulles
airport that's a [__] that's a big
airport so i was like
you know why not
why [__] not
you know so i
i read the script last night i [__]
went over the [__] sides i don't know
them yet they're pretty interesting big
jewels was like this [__] the sides i
got
was about a guy you know big jules is
gambling and he [__] loses a dice and
he wants to take a marker out and then
he goes but hold on we got to play with
my dice the guy's like what dice and he
shows up with dice with no [__]
numbers on it and he goes what is this
he goes i got him specially made he goes
where are the numbers because i got rid
of the numbers
he goes so how do we know he goes i know
in my head i know where the numbers are
placed i [__] died a laughter so you
know what i'm gonna [__] go for it
[__] it what do i got to lose what am i
doing with my life this friday though i
will be in [__] mississippi
at the [__] uh
the brick show we are doing
the last [__] show this friday i am
definitely showing up
uh i don't know what's gonna happen out
of newark airport i am not getting stuck
because i'm flying back with bert
to atlantic city you know burke flies
private so i called them up as a dog
here's the deal i'll take commercial
down there but i'm not getting stuck on
[__] labor day weekend in mississippi
that doesn't even sound [__] good
right there they never even made a movie
named stuck in mississippi people are
leaving las vegas and [__] going back
to cali
but nobody's ever gotten stuck
in [__] mississippi so i'm not gonna
be the first cuban that's gonna get
stuck i'm gonna go down there i'm
[__] ready for you [__] i
don't know where you're driving because
a couple people hit me up on twitter are
you gonna be there friday i'm going i
talked to bird it's [__] confirmed
i'm going to mississippi i'm doing that
[__] kick-ass show with mark i'm
looking forward to seeing the guys
the dj everybody and then i fly back
saturday i gotta go to my [__] girl's
wedding florentines are getting married
in neptune new jersey
there's no wedding i just got to go to
the reception thank god
and then we got another [__] kids
party after that so we got a packed
[__] labor day can you believe it's
[__] labor day already guys
[__] labor day and i got to be honest
with you guys i was telling my wife on
the drive up yesterday and i'm not
saying this you know i'm not one of
these guys that [__] says it just to
say it
this is the best summer i've had in a
long [__] time
guys
i'm done
like i i [__] got shot at i got
thrown in jail i found my mother dead
you know i've been stuck i'm done
like i just want to giggle now i just
want to smoke my little reefer
i took some [__] reefer down to oh
i took that tremendous og down there
i got to north carolina i brought
rolling papers
you know guys and i didn't bring a
grinder
so i had to cut that weed with a scissor
oh
i was rolling joints the first two days
and i was getting [__] blasted
i have no reason a lot of you guys i
probably put on 10 pounds the first two
days and not eating sweets
they were cooking we didn't eat that one
restaurant while we're down there
six nights you know how nice that felt
do you know how [__] nice that felt
just to have home meals every night
a portuguese family came
that [__]
she made some black beans
oh my god
some black beans and she puts chorizo in
it for flavor and onions
and garlic
over white rice and then the other dude
is korean
he's from a great [__] listen these
people i went down there with a great
people i wouldn't put my hands with
anybody i've met these people since i
got here our kids [__] hang out
together
and we've become you know i hang on like
six different crews this is my number
one crew i love these guys the one guy's
a garbage man in the city he works at
the [__] uh
place big dude makes [__] great half
of them up from staten island
you know like they're all staten island
italian and irish and [__] and the
portuguese people from [__] newark
the second night
i think the second or third night she
made black beans my [__] eyes were
rolling back and the korean dude took
[__] short ribs
and marinated these [__] for
four days like he's marinated them
before and i've had him but that day
he left them in there for four [__]
days
now
for you guys who know me every short rib
with [__] korean dressing
that's 11 points so two short ribs is 22
[__] points and black beans and rice
is six
i was like [__] it i didn't eat no more
than two of those [__] short ribs
but i got a big dish of [__] black
beans and rice and here's where it gets
better
she chopped up garlic and put it on the
bottom like an inch of garlic on a dish
and then chop like two inches of onions
on top so you could put it all over your
[__] black beans and rice
you know uncle joey took that extra
garlic dog i was farting
all [__] night when you could smell
your fart through a [__] sleep apnea
machine
that's when you know your asshole's
working double time you understand me
when i fart and i got the sleep apnea
machine on with a little [__] hole
that vents air out that way the excess
air
and i could a fart creeps into that
little [__] tiny people
that's success you understand me
speaking of success we were talking
about different things for the mind
and what works you know like for me
waking up in the morning and [__]
sitting outside like a momo and looking
around and saying my gratitude
these are all things that help you get
grounded like for me i had a lot of
problems when i moved here
and these are things that helped me get
grounded but one of the things that
helped me
and it's still helping me guys you know
like i'm down to twice a month now
and it's just talk therapy it's [__]
helped me out tremendously so before we
go on
uh a word from our sponsors and now for
a word from our sponsor better help
listen like i spoke before you got to
take care of your mind
we spent so much time taking care of
what's outside but so little of taking
care of the most important body part the
brain for years i did it also don't feel
bad investing time and energy in mental
health is crucial to your happiness
eating right working out that all helps
but there's no substitute for talk
therapy better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient and affordable
listen like i told you during the
podcast i still talked to dana twice a
month it's not every week i cut it down
you could go with video you could go
with phone or chat therapy sessions or
you could choose not to see anyone on
the camera it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you could be
matched with a therapist
in 48 hours if you try to get a face to
face with a therapist today it's going
to take you two or three months half of
them are booked out half them don't even
want to see clients face to face so
better help is online therapy it's so
much more affordable than personal
therapy you're going to flip and the
results are going to be tremendous so
what i'm going to do for you is this
joint listeners get 10 off your first
month with betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhelp.com
diaz and now back to the show we're back
[__] don't forget go to betterhelp
speaking of better help let me tell you
something else i realized last week that
it works both [__] ways one of my
i have a trait that's [__] bad
and it's not something it's not a
[__] uh
addiction
it's just a trait it runs in my [__]
genes and it's it's a horrible
for years i thought about how bad it was
because it doesn't let me sleep at night
okay
and what i'm talking about is being a
vengeful person
since i was a kid i don't know what the
[__]
i didn't like anything like people
[__] doing [__] to me i still
remember moving to new york city and
like in the first grade second grade
first grade a kid did something to me
one day
like threw something at me or some [__]
and i waited like [__] two weeks till
it snowed and i blasted them in the head
with a [__] snowball they rushed me
to the [__] principal's office and my
mother was like what happened like a
couple weeks ago i had to keep me with a
[__] shoe or something like that but
there was teacher there and i was a
little scared and there was other kids
there so i just waited for outside one
day with a [__] snowball and blasted
him right in the [__] ear he was
bleeding we were like six you know
and uh it's funny because that my my
daughter's watching narcos and she
[__]
she [__] you know she watches narcos
to learn spanish we won't watch it
together
that's the excuse we give my wife to
watch narcos and she loves pablo escobar
and stuff so
you're not going to believe it so my
wife says to her the other day so what
do you what are you learning on narcos
what did you learn those two seasons she
goes my favorite is
that means son of a [__] you know and
i'm my wife looks at me like what the
[__]
i go listen sometimes to initiate people
into a language you gotta teach them the
bad words first that's what gets people
excited and i look at like a lot of
people say to me well joey you know
you're a little foul-mouthed you got
don't blame me
don't play me
blame you [__] blame your
[__] children blame your parents that
are your age when in the 70s when you
came here
people were nice like when i was growing
up in new york city people were very
nice to me but the first words i didn't
learn were [__] hello i learned like
suck my dick it was something not good
and i was thinking about this it was
something not good
and when my daughter said that to me i
thought it was story when i still
remember this like it was [__]
yesterday
i across the street from 205 west 88
when i was growing up i don't know
what's there now not on the amsterdam
side but on the 88th street side was a
laundromat i don't know
something happened one day
with a girl from my class she was in the
first grade i thought we were friends
her mother was walking like when they
walked down
and i said something to her
and like next day i go to [__] school
and they're like jose you gotta go to
the principal's office i'm in the
[__] first grade i'm [__] my
pants and [__] the mom is in there
with the daughter
and she's like i don't know if you
understood what you told my daughter
yesterday but it's unacceptable and i'm
like i don't even know what i said
and the lady's like whoa it's too dirty
to mention the thing and then i don't
know
says something like i suck and suck my
dick i didn't know what sucked my dick
meant but that's what the kids were
teaching me to say like don't say hello
say suck my dick and i fell for it like
an [__] that i am so i told this girl
hey suck my dick and next thing you know
i got in trouble no [__] relation to
what we're talking about here i just
want to let you know
a little something i came up with last
week so
i'm sitting there and i'm like [__] you
know
i mean my mom like i was always a
vengeful person but then when my mom
told me the story about
her sticking up for her sister
and stabbing the guy in the back and all
this [__] i was like what
you know and then as i got older i
watched the chinese connection all those
movies i watched as a kid
triggered what i already had that was
wrong which is my
revenge whatever you know like anybody
who [__] with me i got to get them at
some point in my life i'll wait in the
bush and i'm very good at it that's the
thing about me i'm [__] great at it
so i just sit back and relax but i was
thinking about how bad it was couple of
years ago i'm like this has to stop
and at times i remember rogan used to
have a joke 20 years ago when we first
met
about that
thing stayed with him
that he was still mad at a guy
from five years earlier that had
asked for oranges he was like a pool
cleaner or something like that
and he asked joe if he could take some
oranges on the way out and joe goes yeah
help yourself
and joe was going in the shower and joe
said when he was in the shower he could
see the guy outside just taking a bunch
of [__] oranges you know i just
like more than what he should have and
he go and joe said for years i wanted to
tell that guy what the [__] but i didn't
in it and it ate me up i don't know how
the context i don't know how he used it
i have the same problem
like
people always go to me oh well joe rogan
says that you were funnier
after he met you three or four years
after he met you at the store yeah
because i had so many things on my mind
at that time when i met joe i was still
plotting my wife's death and her [__]
husband at the time i was very immature
and i was plotting their [__] debt
that was what i all you know i didn't
care about stand up i knew at that time
that it was just something i was doing
to keep me busy until i could stab them
both of them but
then i got a life i met a nice girl i
got my wife and now i look at them and i
pray for them and there's nothing wrong
with that you know
but i had a lot of problems with that
vengeful [__] you know i would always
say something to people i would always
wait
and i enjoyed it like reminding people
hey man
years ago you did this to me now it's
your [__] turn to get it back to you
you know i enjoyed it because it's true
i don't like when people [__] with you
when they're in a circle but it doesn't
matter i became a very vengeable person
over the [__] years
but i also thought about the other side
of that ying in the yang
because
yeah it took me down some bad [__]
roads and thank god i didn't do all the
things to people that i wanted
when i was mad at them like i always say
thank god
thank god i didn't act it out you know i
did act out a lot of things kidnappings
and [__] like that and
rob and drug dealers but i never acted
out 50 percent of the [__] i wanted to
do
but then i was thinking about it i'm
like you know
wait a second
that revenge [__]
works there
but it's also worth me another part of
my life
and it's just me doing things
like i never want to fail at something
even though you have to you have to fail
at things to get better at them
i always had a strong belief that i
didn't want to [__] fail at things
you know so
there's times when i pick something up
i don't know like that when i was a kid
i don't know we got into this
conversation we were talking about
my wife asked me what happened with
basketball she goes she didn't know the
whole story that one of my friends and
me were talking and she heard some [__]
that we were saying like all that day
we were talking about the summer before
my mother died how
i didn't want to play basketball i was
going to play football and i started
[__] uh
bleeding like i started spitting blood
and i got rushed to the hospital and was
just but i always hated quitting
basketball
as i got older i hated it more and more
but there was nothing i could do i was
26 or 27 years old what do you want to
do start from scratch and try to make it
into the nba
it's not gonna work so
but that lesson when i quit basketball
at my freshman year stuck with me
forever
because i never wanted that to happen
again
so
anything that i do that fails
and it's maybe it's not failure maybe
it comes into your life when you're not
ready for it
are you with me on this because there's
a lot of things that have come into my
life
that i appreciated but i wasn't ready
for
and at one point i i was ready and i
said okay now i'm ready to take this
challenge you know it's funny
in
1996 i wrote a [__] joke
a [__] guy got stabbed uh the rush
russian the jewish
whatever
got stabbed okay and
he got killed i forget what his name was
i'm sorry i i can't keep on top of all
these [__] names
but i had a joke you know i like the guy
got stabbed and i go you know what that
guy got stabbed because forty dollars is
forty dollars
the guy who stabbed him was jewish or
something
and i made a joke like
he got stabbed because in his world
forty dollars is forty dollars and i
it's either that joke or there was
another joke that i i can't come to mind
it was 1996 1997 guys
and there was only
one person who would laugh at that
[__] joke every time i did it in an
open mic setting and that was josh wolfe
he laughed for two reasons because the
joke was funny but he also laughed
because the joke would bomb
all right like nobody in the room got it
and about a month i couldn't figure out
how to [__] set it up how to lay i
couldn't figure out anything maybe put
some padding around it
i couldn't figure out how to [__] say
this joke and one day i was talking to
somebody who was a great writer in
seattle her name was kathy sorbo a girl
that's [__] great i don't she was on
mtv
really good looking great lady married
and she goes maybe
you wrote that joke
and it's ahead of where your comedy is
at first it offended me like i was like
that's not a nice thing to say she goes
no
listen to what i'm saying
you know you had a a a [__] great
idea she goes i love the joke i'll buy
it from you i forget what the joke was
guys it's killing me but
she goes maybe you're not prepared to
say that joke yet
and i listen to it and i go hey maybe
and what she meant was that that joke
it was a 10-year comic joke
and i was still at a six year point so i
didn't know how to deliver that joke
it's a really hard pill to swallow when
somebody says it to you but once you
think about it you're like oh okay and
i'd never forget this
ten years later i brought the joke back
and guess what
it killed
it killed every [__] time maybe it
was a delivery difference
maybe i had more confidence when i was
saying it who knows
the joke was great it just wasn't ready
for me at the time okay
you know in 2000 whatever i joined jiu
jitsu before my daughter was born uh
guys i had two podcasts a week i was
doing two other podcasts a week and i'm
going on the road three times a [__]
month
it was like one class a week i go to two
classes a week i never really improved i
just hung on i
didn't listen so i picked up bad habits
in jiu jitsu i picked up really [__]
bad habits
and i did it for like four years and i
got nowhere i really didn't i would do
the same [__] every time and that was it
and i took it and then one day i ripped
my [__] left hamstring at the comedy
store and then the pandemic hitting
there was no more jiu jitsu and i got to
tell you through all the moves and all
this [__] and the podcast i was like
i'm not happy on how i left jiu-jitsu
till this day i'm not happy so when i
got here i went online and i looked and
i found
hollis crazy and i went up there one day
and i talked to him and
then two weeks later i got the knee
surgery and i was out of it i thought i
was done with jiu jitsu forever
but then i was like i can't and i'm like
whoa whoa whoa john jock
is missing fingers one of the greatest
professors in this country a great
eddie's teacher eddie bravo's teacher
john jacques is great but he's got a
handicap he's like i don't know what
hand it is he's missing
fingers and he still grabs you because
it's an art
and no matter how you could still you
can learn how to work with it tony
naomi's missing fingertips a guitar
great guitar player rips out the [__]
he figured out a way how to play when
you really want to do something you
figure out a way so i figured the bum
knee i can't do neon belly no more i
can't do a lot of things i can't pass on
my left side there's a ton of things i
can't do no more but there's a way i
could do it now and now i do it and i'm
happy about i'm not the best guy in the
world i don't go in there and fly
through the air
but i go you know
and the same thing is happening to me
like
with jokes would stand up like if i
would have a bad like i had a bad
weekend at columbus when i first started
headlining in 2011 i had a bad weekend
at columbus
and i swore to go i didn't give a [__]
about money and nothing i'm gonna go
back there
and [__] them up and what made it worse
was that the club owner is cool as [__]
the man is just cool as [__] i love them
but for some reason they didn't book me
for two [__] years
so i was like
they didn't book me because i ate a bag
of dicks you know and i was pretty
[__] embarrassed by i mean i told my
agent i go i ate a bag of dicks
i wasn't ready to headline i was all
over the place i had my moments i was
funny nobody complained
but i know i could have done a lot
better
and guys the next time i went to [__]
columbus i [__] destroyed them
i and i guess what i destroyed them
every time after that i still remember
the night that we were in columbus for 4
20 and the kid [__] passed down the
audience and the ambulance came and got
him and they [__] his friends left
him there tremendous [__] [__] i had
great times in columbus but i went back
there and i [__] laid it down
i'm very vengeful like that
and i i thought about whoa whoa whoa
okay my revenge side is shitty
but how i care about if i do well or not
i like that you know one of the things
guys that was really eating away with me
i put up that duck donuts picture and
then uh
a couple weeks ago i went to a game with
my daughter and i put some pictures up
from the baseball game and then two
nights later
one of the families like we're gonna go
to dinner tonight and i made some videos
at dinner and we were [__] around
with little pink things on my instagram
and i had a great time it's for the kids
you know but people always go to me joey
we like what you're doing
you know you're a good dad you try
i don't feel that way guys i don't feel
that way at all because in my world i
have a [__] failure i have an
asterisk as a failure as a father and as
a [__] husband
so that will stick with me forever okay
i i was such a failure as a husband i
didn't want to get married again and i
was such a failure as a father that
between you and i and the third [__]
god up there in the sky
at like the six month mark i was ready
to leave my wife not because i didn't
love the guys not because
but because i didn't want to disappoint
somebody again
i didn't want to disappoint somebody
again and then i caught myself and i go
i smack myself in the face and i go joy
what the [__] you talking about
you're doing this and this time you're
going to do it the right way you know
and that's it and it's going to take
time and for me i feel like a hypocrite
at times you know when i put those
videos up and all those other things but
guys it doesn't matter
that i feel like a hypocrite
i'm trying to be a good [__] dad i'm
trying to
be a family guy i'm trying to be home
i'm trying to do things like i said this
thing i did last week i would never do
this anybody who knows me knows i'm a
three-day guy
after three days i start itching i find
excuses why to [__] leave it's just
it's just the way some people are you
know and that's just the way i'm like
i've accepted it i talked to my brother
yesterday george when he told me that
you back and we go yeah
he goes i gotta be honest with you
this is the first trip you've ever been
on that you didn't complain to me one
time
you didn't want to come home
you didn't complain i didn't even my
wife said to me that the wives like
listen
we've known this guy for two years this
is the happiest
we've ever [__] seen him you know
and guys at the end of the week i just
want to be a dad i just want to know
what that feels like i want to know what
you guys experienced
to just be normal not having to leave
every week and come back with a [__]
story i don't want to miss anything i
gotta go you know i agreed with bert to
go to uh mississippi on thursday
friday guess what i got an email right
after i agree with birth that they're
having a softball party on friday night
they're gonna practice and they're gonna
get pizza and ice cream and
again you know what there'll be other
practices but that's not what i'm doing
here
i wanna be
i wanna be here for the her i wanna be
here for my wife i wanna be here for my
friends i like my people and they but
you know
last week solidified something else and
again
i love north bergen and i love the
people i made up there and i love the
life i made up there
i'm embarrassed about the way how i left
north bergen i got no reason to lie no
but i'm very embarrassed
about my reputation up there as a
[__] thief and a [__] nomad but
in my world i've i'm not a thief no more
i'm not a [__] nomad
but in my world it's very tough like a
lot of people go why don't you come up
here as much as you do you know why guys
because
i don't want to walk up here like
nothing ever happened
something happened you know i'm coming
up on a 40th anniversary robbing a
[__] jewelry store
now nobody remembers that today nobody
cares about it nobody talks about
anybody but guess who does or care about
it i do
i do
i mean every time i drive past the
jewelry store i beep at them for good
luck they're not even there no more but
my point is i'm one of those guys that
takes what i did seriously in the past i
know i come on here and i've been coming
on with the church and all this [__] for
years and i was giggling about it but i
wanted to get it out of me
so i was at peace with it that was part
of what the church was about and the
joint
for me to make peace and now we got a
book coming out next year and that'll be
that's it you guys have heard it all
we've painted all the pictures for you
but this picture you've never heard
it's crazy how i took revenge on
i lost as a dad
i lost as a husband and i tell you when
you lose his dad
and you lose as a husband
in my world you're a [__] mutt and
that's exactly what i did
so i'm not too happy with my situation
as of the past as of what i do now what
i've been doing the last two years and
it's like i told my brother yesterday on
the phone when he asked me
i said george you didn't believe me when
i told gentlemen when i moved here two
years ago it was to end the [__] it
was to end it i did it i had a great
time i loved doing the theaters i still
enjoy doing stand-up but not the level
it doesn't mean that much to me anymore
it doesn't mean that much to me i don't
care about a special
i see these people running around you
know now i heard something even more
[__] disturbing mike and i were
talking before and mike's like i asked
michael i haven't seen mike in a week
what have you been seeing on the
internet whatever nothing but i heard
something so [__] disturbing
yesterday
that i'm happy i'm not doing this
because i would have to say something
you ready for this
our brother little international lee
syed
went to dallas this week
and he went to
see brian simpson funny [__]
i'll see him friday night and
[__] uh
mississippi i'm looking forward to it
he went by himself
he
reached out to brian brian compton the
tickets you know he just wanted to go
see brian brian's a funny guy
and he had two drinks or something and
he said he gets his check and
30 something dollars
he looks at the check
there's an 18 service charge
when the waitress came over lee goes i
just want to double check with her i
asked her hey
what's this 18 percent boy is this your
tip
and he goes very like upset she looked
at him and she goes no
that's 18
the club is putting on top of everything
right no they put on all the checks
and he was like joey and i tipped her
because i didn't want to think i [__]
robbed her
but he goes that's [__] up i go
bro these people and these are the same
these big chains of clubs man
when the pandemic hit i just wanted to
see where they were at so i called them
up and i go listen
as you could see all these comics that
you hope and go back because i thought i
know for me
if i would have gone back into comedy i
would have gone back to clubs for a few
months got warmed up a little bit and
then busted into theaters and then
whatever you know but i don't think
people did that people just [__] comics
blew my mind they just went right into
theaters they didn't miss a [__] beat
you know so i called them up and i'm
like hey man as you could see i just
wanted to test the waters
i know as you could see uh all these
[__] big acts are going into theaters
i i don't want to do theaters to be
honest i don't want to do two theaters a
weekend so i would love to come back to
your club you know to your clubs and
maybe put a little tour together
put a little banner up with you guys
maybe get some sponsors you know what
i'm saying but
these are the percentages i want and i
hit them with something out of my mind
just to push them there just to open up
their mind or get them thinking a little
bit remember to be a good [__] comic
to be a good musician you got to be a
salesman and you got to have that
[__] mind we discussed this already
so i just threw out a [__] number out
there adam to blow his [__] pants off
because
you have nobody else to do what i could
do so let me go in there and do it
and we'll [__] all work together
they've been good to me i've been good
to them a little kinky i have to catch
them from time to smack their hand every
once in a while and go
look oh we didn't know you know one of
those people
so i called them up and i go listen if i
do decide to do this this is the number
i won they were like their [__] pants
blew up now we can't give you that i go
well then you won't see me let me tell
you something
you guys got huge loans over the [__]
pandemic
and
you stayed open
people going to your clubs getting
[__] covered left and right
you didn't give a [__] i did i [__]
did so
because of the damage you [__]
did now
i want what's coming to me like anybody
else would we all ask you got your pe
loans
all these big [__] clubs and
everything got that ppe loans don't
think that they were [__] sweating
bullets during the pandemic there's a
comedy club that got 10 million dollars
she got two [__] clubs don't tell me
what the [__] is going on here now they
want to charge 18
on top of all this which not a dime goes
to the entertainer
not a dime goes to the performer not a
dime goes to the [__] waiters guys
you know i i agreed to take these
tickets in new york and i love that i'm
doing it and i'm excited about doing
them and i'm not [__] excited about
is where they raised those ticket prices
to i kept them at forty dollars for
[__] everybody so everybody could go
that's a fair [__] price
so i'm not too [__] happy about this
[__] that they raised them up to four
dollars 300
i'm not happy with this
yeah i'll get you some tickets you know
but
no
no and you people i'm telling you right
now i find out one of your [__]
pays over 40 dollars for those tickets
i'll [__] never talk to you again do
not pay i'm not worth over 40 hours it's
guys
so for them to do this i'm gonna put
tickets on sale in a couple weeks for
philly same thing
40 [__] dollars that's enough that's
more than enough we could all but then
again
they wanted to put the tickets on sale
for philly two weeks ago i'm like are
you [__] [__] i know what you're
gonna do
you're gonna [__] resell the tickets
and then [__] buy them all and then
resell them to my people for 200 and you
know what i'll cancel the [__] gig
and now with this 18 percent guys that's
why you know what it's time to support
your mom and pop comedy [__] clubs
that club you didn't want to go in
because they gave you heartburn for
nachos pretty soon when the word gets
out
that [__] and these people are doing
this all these comics these young guys
are gonna because all these clubs are
doing it now i'm hearing what they're
doing to these young comics it's it's
not [__] good
they did it to me and i accepted it
because
i didn't give a [__] i'm a criminal i
was just happy to be
doing stand-up i didn't give a [__] what
you paid me
it was a lot better than what the life i
previously had but these guys are
getting [__] 250
to emcee for a weekend and they want you
to pay for your hotel and your [__]
affair guys
come on
come on now you can't even sit in the
[__] luggage for 250 luggage pays 100
hours to [__] sit in there so it's
like come on guys
it's time to [__] you young comics to
start your own venues you know
like i've been telling you for years
guys
some of the best comedy [__] rooms
i've ever done of
comics
that got a little bar they got a little
room in the back
they pay they charge they have good
[__] food and you don't own the
building you just go home at the end of
the [__] night
you go home at the end of the night you
make a little paycheck you don't have to
get insurance nothing
and that's the way this is going to go i
am in [__] shocked that i heard that
[__] 18 [__] percent on top of the
tickets this the
[__] he called me today this morning
he told me that the credit card company
called him to double check on the 18
percent plus the [__] tip how's that
one for you even the credit card company
said what the [__] is going on
when a credit card company says what the
[__] you call your credit card company i
want to buy a boat
okay i only have 500 000 left i'm
exaggerating here but you could call
your credit card company and always bump
them
you know that right if you pay your
bills you call them every 90 days hey
can i get an extra 250 i'm thinking of
burying my cat you know whatever the
[__] excuse you have
anyway i love you [__] with all
my heart man
i'm excited for labor day weekend
because uh
my world starts today i'm not even
waiting out people i'm gonna after labor
day i'm gonna put the white socks away
and then we're gonna go back to the gym
i'm not even wait until next monday
i'm starting today i'm dropping down to
250 i got a thousand [__] goals for
the last four months of the year
i'm gonna give you guys the best shows i
can in new york
the weed is getting stronger over at
laughing gas with my tremendous i should
be getting a new batch of [__] uh
rainbow ruts pretty [__] soon and a
new batch of [__] tremendous
and that's it guys i'll see half you
[__] this friday
and if not i'll see you used the
following week at [__] uncle
vinnie's and if not i'll see you the
following week
at the sony theater i love you
[__] with all my heart
stay black and i'll see you [__]
wednesday
tip top magoo
i appreciate you guys watching thank you
for the support but now for a word from
our sponsor
better help listen you got to take care
of yourself and you also got to take
care of your mind the brain is a
beautiful thing invest in time and
energy and mental health is crucial to
happiness that's why i'm with better
help better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient and affordable
i've been with them for over a year guys
i started with four sessions a month i'm
down to two
with dana and i feel 150 percent better
you're like joey what's better help
better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient and affordable
because you're not going to find a
therapist that's going to see you right
away right now with better help i'll
have you hooked up with a therapist in
under 48 hours and it's much more
affordable than in person therapy it
worked for me guys so do me a favor
joint listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
diaz d-i-a-z again that's betterhelp.com
diaz also
football season is upon us there's a new
season with a new set of rules i know
you would whatever other service last
year but it's [__] draft kings year
sometimes you got to switch up to change
your luck draftkings is to celebrate the
return of [__] football then you can
bet five dollars in any football game
and get 203 bets it's the beginning of
the nfl and i want you to be prepared
experience the thrill of draftkings
early win promotion
get up to seven points and you win but
on any nfl team you choose and if your
team leads by seven points at any point
in the game you get [__] paid who's
better than you draftkings is safe
secure and reliable depositing
withdrawal at your own convenience
download the draftking sportsbook app
today it's a new season [__]
let's do it we got college football we
got [__] pro football and we got
baseball coming up the playoffs that's
code joey when you download the
draftking sportbook app
joey to get 203 bets instantly when you
place five dolls on any football team
again
draftkings is the official sports
betting partner of the nfl minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply so
show notes read the show notes for
details now do me a favor download the
draftking sportsbook app and let's bust
your [__] bookmaker's [__] you
understand me
the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen the holiday season's
coming [__] santa claus is putting on
weight as we speak
so do me a favor before you start
shipping and sending if you haven't
started prepping for the chaos of
holiday mailing and shipping you're
already [__] slipping so stamps.com
has everything you need to make life
easier it's virtual 24 7 post office no
line no traffic no hassles my wife and i
have been with them for like 12 years
stamp.com gives you access to post
office and ups shipping services right
from your [__] computer i'm
going to save you 30 off usps rates and
i'm going to save you 86 off ups all you
need is your regular compute and a
printer that's it no special supplies no
equipment you'll be up and running in
minutes i don't care if you have four
employees or 800 employees
stamps.com is for you so get ahead of
all day chaos get started with
stamps.com today sign up with promo code
joey for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and a free
digital scale no long-term commitments
just go to stamps.com and click on the
microphone at the top of the page and to
code joey it's that easy i want to thank
stamps.com i want to thank better help
and i want to thank draftkings but most
importantly i want to thank you savages
for always having my back have a great
monday have a great labor day if i don't
see you and stay black talks up his
uncle joey loves you
you